let's talk about what our friend
adam's best friend donald trump had to
say about facebook and twitter
he recently decided to sue those guys
this is a reuters story
trump sues facebook twitter and google
claiming censorship former u.s president
donald trump on wednesday filed lawsuit
against those guys
as well as their chief executives
alleging their unlawfully silenced
conservative viewpoints a lawsuit filed
in the u.s district
court of miami allegedly
california-based social media platform
violated the right to freedom of speech
guaranteed by the first amendment u.s
constitution trump is seeking
class action status for the lawsuit
meaning the world they he would
represent the interest of other users of
twitter facebook google
youtube who alleged they have been
unfairly silenced he filed three
lawsuits
making similar allegations one against
facebook mark zuckerberg one against
twitter jack dorsey and one against
google
sundar sundar okay thoughts
on this lawsuit i'm gonna shock you
let's hear it but actually i'm good with
this i hope
he i'm glad you are yeah i mean because
we're talking about this before you
support this
meaning if there's anything that i'm not
a fan of that's the big tech
overreach that's happening in this
country right now conservative voices
they're they're you know
running off to platforms like parlor and
other platforms that are happening right
now i'd like to see where this goes
you know at the same time you know these
private companies are going to be able
to say look we can have we could do what
we want
i know trump has not been a fan of
section 230 either is biden
section 230 is the thing that's big up
for debate uh but i'd like to see where
this goes from here
however here's my prediction i know you
talked about you don't want trump to run
you think he's gonna run i'm gonna say i
think trump is 1000 running in 2024
but i actually do not think he has a
chance unless he actually wins his
lawsuit and can get on these platforms
without twitter without facebook without
youtube without all that stuff
he doesn't have a channel way too early
to say he doesn't have a chance there's
so many things i can change in this
country
um my biggest takeaway from this is how
he claims that facebook
was in cahoots essentially with the
centers for disease control
and fauci and to advance the only the
narrative that the defendants and dr
fauci subscribe i think you mean fousey
yeah fousey
by the way he's 80 years old by the way
and the highest paid government employee
um so there you go i want to watch that
because
now what are you hearing all you're
hearing about is the delta variant
yesterday we already mentioned about the
mass going back on the kids i'm worried
about where things are going with covid
because they've used it in the past
they're going to weaponize it again
and i'm scared what do you think pat uh
i think you know the trump has sued
1900 people prior to him running for
president he's used to being litigious
and soon people
what that means out of his 1900 lawsuits
like is he going to win or make any kind
of a head wave i don't know i don't know
if anything's going to take place over
there
there's too many people that would love
for him
to not have the freedom to voice his
opinion on facebook twitter and youtube
and those people are on the left now
somehow someway
i will give you timing and i'll give you
a prediction here you ready
i'm gonna give you the craziest
prediction here and i think i'm gonna be
right
when did pfizer announce that their
vaccine is ready
it's like right after the election two
days after the election you know when
trump's going to be free to
have facebook twitter and youtube back a
day after election
midterms not midterms 2024
he will be back on facebook twitter and
youtube in december of 2024.
that is my prediction and i'm sticking
to it and a people of power
no timing they've done a great job with
us strategically manipulative
dark dirty but they're going to play
that card and they're going to say yes
let's drag out this lawsuit
mr trump you won but december 2024. by
that time you're 78 which means for you
to run at 82
will not happen that means we will never
get a second term
with the president you don't think that
they're cunning and conniving
of course so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye